rami nektar parras der mann hier rechts
hinter mir auf dem screen wird von der
polizei gejagt mit internationalem
haftbefehl
denn für die ermittler ist klar der
hells angels boss ließ einen angeblichen
verräter eiskalt erschossen seine leiche
zerstückelt und anschließend im reinen
versenken und was glauben sie wie dieser
mutmaßliche killer jetzt lebt vielleicht
versteckt und abgetaucht in irgendeinem
kellerloch ohne telefon ohne internet
dann schauen sie auf die exklusiven
recherchen von frank schneider
ein mutmaßlicher mörder auf der flucht
ramin nektar passt er verhöhnt deutsche
fahnder und auch seine opfer auf
instagram für seine 122 tausend follower
postet der 33-jährige dreist videos und
fotos in denen er sich im iran stolz in
freiheit zeigt dann ein ausschnitt aus
dem film forrest gump in im forst weg
läuft das projekt passt das nennt sich
auf der flucht sein es folgt ein foto im
liegestuhl unter wasser das ist
abtauchen und das ist noch nicht alles
am ende der proms rocker insta story ein
video in dem der hells angel breit
könnten mit sonnenbrille im liegestuhl
am pool ich dazu schreibt er und nennt
sich das als wolle er damit sagen ich
bin nicht auf der flucht ich bin nicht
abgetaucht ich genieße mein leben das
geht auch nur weil der iran eigene
landsleute nicht ausliefert weitere
videos auf seinem instagram account
zeigen ihn mit seinem lamborghini posen
einmal drehte auf dem heißen motor ein
spiegelei wohl um allen zu zeigen was er
für ein toller kerl ist sein ganzer
körper ist tätowiert neben üblichen
hells angels symbolen ziert auch ein
hakenkreuz seinen oberarm
gefahndet wird nach héctor parra ist
wegen des mordes an km im jahr 2014
dessen leichnam zerstückelt im rhein
gefunden wurde vergangene woche war bei
einer großrazzia ein mittäter in
mönchengladbach gefasst worden es ist
aber natürlich im programm nicht so
einfach an informationen zu kommen jetzt
konnten wir heute hier zu schlagen und
haben eben viele gesucht und auch eine
festnahme getätigt von einem der
hauptverdächtigen in dem verfahren bild
reporter frank schneider war vor ort
dabei für uns begibt er sich nochmal auf
spurensuche an die verschiedenen
auffindeort in der leichenteile
nach aussagen des kronzeugen und auch
nach ansicht der ermittler der
mordkommission hier in duisburg von die
täter damals genau in diesem bereich mit
ihrem auto und dann gingen sie mit den
leichenteilen dem torso und einem arm
des ermordeten rockers zu dieser brücke
und dann trieben danach die teile im
rheinpreußen hafen im wasser der torso
wurde später auch hier gefunden der
antrieb in denen rein hinaus und wurde
dort am ufer entdeckt
im februar 2014 wurde hier am rheinufer
das erste leichenteile des ermordeten
rocker km gefunden es war sein arm die
polizei wusste sofort auf grund der
tätowierung es handelt sich um einen
hells angel eine mordkommission wurde
gebildet und die ermittler gaben sieben
jahre lang nicht auf diesen fall endlich
zu klären und haben nun endlich das
ergebnis und wissen was damals hier
passiert ist
und dieser brücke hier wurde der torso
und das trübe wasser des rheinpreußen
hafens beworfen deswegen erinnert bis
heute hier diese trauerstätte an den
ermordeten rocker km seine eltern haben
es eingerichtet man sieht mit einem
blumen herz und auch ein kreuz und sie
sagen sie sind endlich froh dass dieser
mord aufgeklärt wird und hoffen jetzt
dass die beiden flüchtigen täter auch
noch gefasst werden
der kronzeuge führte die ermittler der
duisburger mordkommission zu dieser
brücke hier über den rhein-herne-kanal
er sagte wir haben von dieser brücke
betonklötze ins wasser geworfen darin
sind die leichenteile und auch der kopf
des ermordeten rockers polizeitaucher
rückten dann durchsuchten das wasser des
rhein herne kanals und fanden dann genau
wie von zeugen beschrieben die
betonklötze darin die leichenteile sie
wurden obduzieren das war ganz klar es
sind die leichenteile und der kopf von
gm und es war dann auch klar km ist mit
einem schuss in den hinterkopf getötet
worden
die brutalität der mutmaßlichen mörder
macht bei den razzien am vergangenen
donnerstag den einsatz von
schwerbewaffneten sek beamten und einem
radpanzer nötig wegen des umfang des
einsatzes und auch der gefährdung die
von den tatverdächtigen ausgeht war die
einbindung von spezialeinheiten auch aus
anderen bundesländern in erheblichen
umfang erforderlich und diese
spezialeinheit waren insgesamt an 13
objekten im einsatz dass die hells
angels und bandidos ihren krieg in nrw
auf offener straße kämpften mit dem
innenminister ein dorn im auge
dementsprechend zufrieden zeigte er sich
nach der ersten festnahme im stückl mord
mit den heutigen einsatz haben wir den
rockern gezeigt dass wir am ende nach
langer zeit aber am ende den längeren
atem haben und dass diese rocker kriege
gesühnt werden doch noch kann die akte
nicht geschlossen werden denn zwei
männer sind noch immer auf der flucht
einmal potro charakter passt er soll er
die tödlichen schüsse auf km abgegeben
haben denn er hatte ihn für ein spitzel
gehalten und als präsident des hells
angels charter persönlich wahrgenommen
außerdem sein clubkamerad muster
verhindern dieser wird wegen zweifachen
mordversuchs an einem verfeindeten
bandido und seiner freundin im jahr 2013
gesucht
ja und der festgenommene rocker der hat
sich gegenüber der polizei noch nicht
geäußert aber wir wollen natürlich
weiter über diesen fall sprechen mit
unseren achtung verhandlungen experten
besonderer schmidt die bei uns ist die
stellenleiterin in sachsen anhalt dort
haben sie hunderte polizisten in uniform
geführt und christian matzdorf der mehr
als 30 jahre kripo arbeit auf dem buckel
hat toll dass ihr beide heute bei uns
seid als unser achtung fahndung
expertenteam damals darauf einmal direkt
an sie wenn die polizei in den rocker
einsatz geht was ist daran so gefährlich
rocket ist das haben eine kultur eine
eigene kultur wo brutalität wo gewalt
eben eine ganz besondere rolle spielt
die wird so gerade besonders
hervorgehoben man kann sich auszeichnen
dem mann gewalttätig und brutal ist und
das aufzeigt und am ende gibt es dafür
sogar auszeichnungen es gibt also
tätowierungen oder patches die deutlich
machen wer ist besonders gewalttätig wir
sind wie weiters wenn sie in den rocker
einsatz gegangen also ich habe mir eine
taktik vorher zurecht legen müssen muss
überlegen wie kann ich meine mitarbeiter
mitarbeiter nicht gefährden oder so
ringen wie möglich zu gefährden und ich
habe dann auch entschieden hunde
vorzuschicken einfach um sicherzustellen
dass die ihnen die dort sind nicht auf
die idee kommen gegen die polizisten
hier gewalttätig vorzugehen und das hat
auch ganz gut geklappt frau schmidt
jetzt lassen sie uns direkt rein schauen
in den fall denn das erste was wirklich
so markant ist das ist diese
unglaubliche brutalität das erst einmal
der abgeschnittene arm der eben am rhein
angespült worden ist und dann hier
dieses schaurige foto die polizei die
also mit einer langen stange diesen
torso aus dem wasser fischen muss was
sind das für kriminelle die so brutal
gegeneinander vorgehen
die haben eben auch etwas im kopf was
ein symbol symbolgehalt hat das heißt
wenn da etwas brutal geregelt wird wie
in diesem fall das
öffentlichkeitswirksam wird dann mehrt
sich auch der ruhm dieser gruppe dieser
vereinigung und das hat man hier
offensichtlich gemacht um auch ein
signal zu setzen einmal nach innen
indierocker gemüt die rein aber auch
nach außen um zu zeigen wir sind in der
lage verrät dazu den tieren und wir
bestrafen sie hat das ist etwas was
ihrem ehrenkodex entspricht und ihre
weitere vorgehensweise geschäfte die sie
machen die drücken sie auch mit gewalt
ruhig und vor dem hintergrund passt das
zu dem ganzen profil was diese gruppe ja
auch auszeichnet ist nicht so dass wir
diese unglaublichen straftaten begehen
sondern dass sie sich auch noch auf den
körper schreiben da sind die
tätowierungen die wir uns ja auch
anschauen können einmal hier view hat
dieser mann aus seinem körper stehen und
hier drüben eben der abgetrennte arm der
hier zb diese 1 prozent hat hermannsdorf
an sie die frage für was stehen diese
tipps was bedeuten die die tattoos sind
in gewisser weise ehrenabzeichen die man
auch nur tragen darf wenn die gruppe es
zulässt wenn der kodex ist zuletzt viel
zu viel bedeutet dass dieser mensch
schon einmal ein mann getötet hat einen
menschen getötet hat sowas gibt es auch
bei den bandidos daher ist das dann
expect no mercy beispielsweise und der
macht damit deutlich ich bin besonders
brutal und ich schrecke auch vor
tötungsdelikt nicht zurück die an der
wand presenter dieses match ist auch
etwas was man nur als ehrenabzeichen
tragen darauf mann gehört zu der gruppe
der ein prozent rocker die sich nicht an
gesetz und recht halten sondern die
einfach vor nichts zurückschreckt und
sich außerhalb des gesetzes stellen
nichts zurückschrecken ist auch gutes
stichwort für die polizeitaktik über die
wir sprechen wollen einmal schauen auf
die bilder von dieser spektakulären
razzia aus nrw und dann sehen wir eben
dass die polizei dort einmal diesen
räumpanzer von rheinmetall im einsatz
hat ein unglaubliches gerät wo man also
vorne in die fassade rhein gerast ist
und dann auf der anderen seite natürlich
das sek im einsatz beamte mit helm mit
schusssicherer weste mit ersatz magazin
frau schmidt warum geht man da so robust
vor ja die polizei weiß natürlich dass
sie in einem sehr gewalt affinen
arbeitet in dem moment gewalt ist eine
tagesordnung interne konflikte werden
mit gewalt gelöst nehmen gerade gesagt
die kultur wird über gewalt nach außen
getragen symbolisiert
geschäftsinteressen wir haben mit gewalt
durchgesetzt und die hemmschwelle gewalt
anzuwenden diese hohe gewalt affinität
bringt man natürlich auch der polizei
und alle anderen die irgendwie stören
die geschäfte stören zum ausdruck dass
weiß polizei und darum agiert man mit
entsprechenden spezialkräften auch mit
entsprechendem gerät und die
spezialeinsatzkommandos der länder und
des bundes sind solche spezialkräfte und
die klingen eben nicht unbedingt an der
tür und bitten auch nicht auf
herkömmlichem weg um einlass machen sie
auch aber sie nutzen in der regel einen
überraschungseffekt und überwinden
barrieren türen wände mitunter auch mit
schwerem gerät was dann zugleich auch
sicherheit bringt für die eigenen kräfte
schon mal fürchten muss sonst vielleicht
selbst beschossen zu werden ja auch das
ist natürlich ein punkt also sonst
survivor wir jetzt hier zur anwendung
kam der bietet natürlich auch
sicherheiten gewissen schutz für die
kräfte die dann im einsatz sind dass wir
uns zum abschluss noch einmal auf diesen
mythos rocker zu sprechen kommen denn
früher da gab es ja dieses bild das eben
ja der rocker das ist dieser mann mit
langer blonder mähne auf der harley
davidson der und wie durch die gegend
fährt und dann eben vielleicht das
rotlichtmilieu kontrolliert genau und
heute wenn man sich diese team fotos
mannschaftsfotos anguckt dann sind das
eben vor allem junge männer mit
migrationshintergrund die offenbar diese
strukturen übernommen haben was ist da
passiert
der motorrad fahrende rocker das ist
eine symbolik die tatsächlich ein stück
weit der vergangenheit angehört das
motorrad hatte ist historisch gewachsen
hat einen hohen stellenwert die
gemeinsam ausfahrten das war das womit
man menschen eingeschüchtert hat wenn
man als in großen konvois durch die
gegend gefahren ist das gehört ein stück
weit der vergangenheit an der
stellenwert ist nicht mehr so ausgeprägt
das geht eben nicht mehr ausschließlich
um das motorrad fahren wir treffen
mittlerweile personen in diesen
vereinigungen an die nicht mehr motorrad
führerschein haben aber dennoch sich als
rocker in einem motorradclub bezeichnet
fühlen und sich entsprechend auch in die
geschäfte einbringen das ist nämlich der
wirklich gemeinsame nenner es geht um
geschäfte es geht um macht es geht um
gebiete es geht um gewalt und
auch der anspruch eines in sich
geschlossene gruppe zu sein mit
tendenzen er vielleicht oder mit bezügen
er in die rechte szene auch das ist
vergangenheit ja mittlerweile haben wir
also tatsächlich auch rockerclubs
rockervereinigung die von menschen mit
migrationshintergrund sogar angeführt
werden frau schmidt hermannsdorf in
vielen dank dass sie heute bei uns waren
und wir sehen uns natürlich bald wieder
dann bei der nächsten ausgabe danke
schonmal und die duisburger polizei die
fahndet öffentlich nach diesem rocker
boss denn es besteht eben der haftbefehl
wegen mordes und die mordkommission
stellt folgende fragen wer kann hinweise
zur arminia karas geben außerdem ist für
die beamten wichtig wer hat damals am
rheinpreußen hafen in duisburg
verdächtige beobachtungen gemacht zeugen
und jeder andere der hinweise geben kann
notfalls auch vertraulich der kann sich
bei der polizei in duisburg melden unter
2800 und wir von achtung fahndung haben
da tatsächlich auch noch ein hinweis und
zwar zum aufenthaltsort von ramin jagd
ab aras denn dieses video hier schauen
sie mal das hat er am wochenende auf
instagram gepostet und man sieht da eben
wie er durch eine nächtliche stadt fährt
unseren kollegen ist es gelungen genau
zu rekonstruieren wo genau sich der
roboter bewegt und wir sehen eine straße
im norden teherans also hier genau
scheint er eben in diesem moment
abgetaucht zu sein